oh my god Wow oh my god Oh dead
Oh that was to fuel hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to
critical mass oh my god this is the
coolest game I've ever played oh man it
seems so simple when I first started but
this game is an epic explosions and the
aliens and the music oh I got all
togethers like one of the coolest games
ever played this is just a demo that
someone made to show off their fossil
engine which is like a game made up of
predetermined points and pixels but got
like a totally destructible environment
and whatnot alright we care I don't even
care about this stuff this game is soo
cool oh hey let me turn up the music
I gotta find he made this music because
this is just epic beyond all the ways oh
here comes hey
okay so I suppose I'm supposed to have
some sort of intelligent commentary
about this game but my brain seems to
not be working right now because just
how amazingly epic this is hologram
I love the rocket launcher the
explosions of blood it's patters all
over the ground
I don't even know why me it's just
badass just look at my face I give no
shits about what I'm doing only crap oh
my god I can't even stand it one of
those games versus like it shouldn't be
this epic but goddamn it it is it's like
one finger death punch is just so
simplistic but so satisfying in every
way love in the debris oh my god this
job I guess I'll Chum when I do we're
all gonna dance huh you guys ready to
dance
Oh
whoa oh I got it on a wide jump up
really high sometimes but I do oh oh
gonna hit it in there we go oh I get
right into the crowd
Oh seriously I don't know why this game
is so damn epic this is like the most
fun I've had playing a game in a long
time it's a spirit simple big yes okay
and now the music's calmed down a little
bit god I'm having way too much fun here
I can't even hug you're quick and
efficient oh I gotta admit all the
things are stock here like the sound for
the gun and the rockets ain't too high
quality but for some reason I don't even
care
whoever this developer is you're a
genius make more and whoever the music
maker is I'm gonna find you I'm gonna
find who you are I'm gonna listen to all
your crap sayin bastards
oh wait my racket I don't even need my
gun I just need my Rockets I'm doing
myself way too much I'm not saying a
single day of important thing right now
and I don't care
oh hey crowd big boys whoa
oh my god about today about today about
tonight get on Oh what did I get
oh my high score I didn't even sing ah
what are you gonna do now huh what's
gonna oh no no I don't want any stay off
my lawn say all my lawn
Sal my lon hi hey you stay on my lawn I
stay on my lawn
babylon babylon hammer on my mom hey how
you stay off and i'll make me blow my
own tree i will already go no no oh I'm
dead get it that's dead net Dada Dada
Dada Dada dead dead dead dead dead dead
dead dead dead oh that Island that
actually might be much more effective
I can do both at the same time
no no
in LA Wow
Oh get some gum wow what did I get
ah what did I get who's my ice core ah
alright so that was critical mass you
can play this game and I know you want
it in the description below totally free
browser-based unity engine it's
amazingly fun play it right now I don't
know what my high-score was I think it
was like 260 something by the way you
saw it it was recorded try to bait it
bring it on so thank you all so much for
watching and if you want to see more
awesome games like this check out my
awesome games playlist leave a like if
you enjoyed this video and as always I
will see you in the next video